bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigente oggi siamo grati
al in it all action che era ero rimasto
in quel punto bellissimo già partiamo
benissimo perché anni e non mi sta
tartassando i maroni e questo è un
vantaggio anche se non so dov'è ragazzi
dove cazzo è giuro che l'ho visto sono
partiti ma beppe giorno grazie
l'umiliazione è stata è stato bello è
stato beppe perfette ragazzi servito è
piaciuto la sede assaggia un commento vi
andava bene da dove è uscito lo sa solo
lui non lo vedo sopra il soffitto è
quello rega non era il soffitto non
erano il soffitto è vava fi veloce mi
chiama giorno perché si è spaccato tutto
quel che succede e cosa sta succedendo
ho pagato il gioco meraviglioso ragazzi
allora non ce la faremo mai a fast a
parte questo dovrà eccolo lì ci siamo in
via mezz'ora per st parte [ __ ] to
alieni e quei robot di merda che prima o
poi di libè coda testa vizio compiti o
sei un figo della madonna mi spiega dove
devo andare che non l'ho capito ragazzi
ragazze ragazzi veloce le giocate
velocissimo il mio dio mio dio ho visto
ho visto cose brutte regala c'è un t
cos'è la lamentela pallino verde e
soppresso poi dimesso prima e sopra
marietto sopra marietto
io sono andato sia andato è andato a
gesù gesù non posso uscire senza che
quel tizio mi trituri la faccia oh beh
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no ma visto non
ha visto non ho visto che botta di culo
pazze titolone a pranzi puoi pagando un
suo dovesse non dove mi posso nascondere
sì sì fanti dio gesù devi morire ma sei
sopra lo zero ma ieri è andato via ma io
posso passare la mia vita in un
armadietto
mi sembra di essere sotto bullismo
ragazzi è bruttissimo no no no no no
devi capire che sei una persona brutta
brutta prop sei brutto quindi teneva
atene melodia togli dal cazzo no no
scherzavo schiacciavo scherzavo no non
ci credo
entrato con la faccia dentro però a caso
io certe cose non le capisco però non
importa ci sono dei bug bellissima ho
trovato la via lega però non ci ho messo
un'ora la scatola si è mossa da sola a
casa
[Musica]
bello entrare nei con botti che non
sanno dove giorno bella giornata vera
salve per che bello che bello dato non
mi puoi prendere luca mi chiami son
cagato addosso non mi ha pagato a me non
va cagato che culo buttato a merda tutto
il locale niente capite che questo gioco
mi da sui nervi
lo capite perché mi dà fastidio che un
pezzente così andiamo in giro a roma
l'ha visto per penso non gli sparavano
mi aveva visto perfetto giorno salve
bell'uomo tolti se il falso che fa
camminando sul niente
non se n'è accorto e stato molto bello
se qualcuno mi spiegasse che cazzo devo
fare ma ascolta c'è gente prodotta qui
buongiorno ma senza mai chi è bello il
suo amico soprattutto ascolta tessera
d'accesso ho trovato la tessera di
grazie a dio devo andare dov'ero prima
praticamente prova che non ci arrivano
ormai non ci arriverò mai non ho visto
come cazzo arrivo dall altra parte se
questo pattuglia qua davanti si è messo
a fare avanti e indietro qua davanti sto
[ __ ]
trovo qui cioè non puoi non puoi
andartene fun cool guarda io adesso
torno indietro c'è un [ __ ] condotto
devo arrivare lì devo arrivare lì
praticamente impossibile ormai veloce
non c'erano già voce sì sì sì sì sì a
godo godo riga non ce n'è bisogno del
suo coro di brutto proprio quella
rapporta con la forza quella da portare
quella porta non c'è sì sì dio mio
se ciò fatta anni anni fa arrivare qui
ci ho messo gli anni è stato veramente
tragico e variamente non lo voglio marco
più vedere tu lurido pezzente di merda
chi cazzo sei tu sei stato qui tutto il
tempo tutto il [ __ ] tempo a fare un
cazzo mentre
che affacciano dell'altrettanta per
inserire il codice preparare
l'ascensione dovremo usare la testa e
bla bla audio bravi il culo veloce anche
anche prima che tp a schiaffi cioè è
stato orribile basta con le mie cose poi
potremo andare vai con cotanto non ci
abbiamo fretta ci sono un alieno alto
quattro metri che vuole squartarli la
faccia però son dettagli perché il lago
del movimento c'è qualcuno oltre a lui
cazzo non aprì la porta ma solo saper ci
avrei scommesso sei stupido porta è
andato è andato scusi lei buon uomo ci
sono mica dei condotti che portano qui
no perché in tal caso cielo nel culo di
quell evento nell'evento perfetto
perfetto stato un brutto bello giocare
soprattutto la mattina giocare sti
giochi
non lo so è divertente vi fate andare
via dal palco sotto ci sono michele
sorpresa dell'uovo kinder
mi sa di no vero dove devo andare codice
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo
cazzo non ce l'ho fatta vero non ce la
fa saba funky lombardo [ __ ] non fa
elettrico ha dovuto figo ho trovato
un'arma lega ho visto solo posso
prendere che cazzo ne sapevo che potevo
prendere sto coso cos'è e cosa adesso
faccio tipo skywalker con la spada laser
ma il problema è che è sceso a yen
quindi che cazzo me ne faccio visto cosa
se ora mi ammazzo a cosa me ne faccio
una sega una sedia
niente sto andando avanti ragazzi ma
anche a caso significa non me lo trovo
davanti non sono contento agli amico
ecco come non detto lasciamolo da solo
perché lui è brutto quindi non deve
avere compagni aprici l'accesso di
caccia ragazzi c'è una tessera qua
dentro dottore la tessera però mi fai un
favore chiudi le porte quando entri
perché già c'è un tizio che gira non
vorrei mai che o lo top guarda e limita
posso creare una molotov no seriamente
2505 perfetto nato le password a caso
2505 ormai sono diventato un hacker
basse possa chiamare quasi un anonymous
proprio il problema è che cazzo cazzo lo
dico io
esploso tutto meraviglioso come se non
bastasse proprio ciò il presentimento
che sto rumore attira lian ragazzi
proprio al tema ciao bellissimo bello
che prima non era così ragazzi
lo sapevo lo sapevo no no no no no no no
non c'e del fuoco senti vai a spegnere
il fuoco farmi un favore le mazzate in
faccia che non è morto non è morto sei
brutto [ __ ] sto sentendo dei passi
bruttissimi libro cazzo ma basta no no
no no no no no no no no no no non ce li
per me ma insomma è morto sono morte
sono morte se buonasera ma ciao belli si
è ammazzata non mia ma ed efficiente era
dietro di me sono entrato nell'arma ge
poi ha domandato è sparito dopo ok va
bene io sono entrato semplicemente in un
armadio mentre lui era qui come cazzo ha
fatto a non vedermi che avevo sentito un
rumore orribile no no no no no no no no
cos'è quel pallino lì che già vede un
pallino brutto il cazzo è questo
salve senti mai visto buongiorno vasto
figlio di [ __ ] ti permetti qualcosa
ma sparati in forma sei stupido fermo
fermo per un pezzo di merda non lo
prende adesso adesso l'ho preso
mamma mia ma rischia effettivamente non
ho pensato che avrei potuto attirare
alien ok ok non mi ha visto non mi ha
visto davvero non va visto pregavano un
po più non ci credo ragazzi non è
possibile che io dovunque vada a troicki
è quella ma avete organizzato un cazzo
di partica [ __ ] e non mi hanno visto è
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo no non ho
regalato
ragazzi che la soddisfazione regga la
soddisfacente
ora ne ha massacrato uno di brutto e poi
sono andato mio dio
che bello se chi ha chiarito lui lo
stronzo no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no non ho mai visto non ho
visto lo chiamavi minchia che culo che
culo dimmi che se ne va ti supplico ma
posso mi chiami qua sotto tra mi sa che
buttare giù i bidoni in questo momento
non è proprio il massimo non avete
madonna no non ti girare ti prego
buongiorno buongiorno quantomeno
pubblico ragazzi dove siamo chiesti ma
c'è tutta gente bella oggi non sto
capendo comunque cos'è usa se il tiro
mio se ce lo fa non ci posso credere non
stai messo proprio bene in questo
momento prevede giorno stronza di merda
non è morta non è ma io c'ho una mira
che ha a quella di mia nonna in faccia
gli schiaffi in faccia
auguri don yuri da [ __ ] che non dove
sei dov'è tuttora s dopo madonna regali
schiaffi che dt rosso tizio se si gira
se si gira mio dio bravo zio bra bebè di
di star tranquillo perché di qua non è
equa che non lo so
medici alla reception perfetto l'ho
trovata raga mio dio c'è qualcuno perché
no perché potrei incaz potrei
leggermente incazzarmi perfetto di qua
no mentre qua dentro
si procederà d'evacuazione un paio di
casi ne so mi ubriaco faccio per il
giorno aspetta cazzo ma cosa ma no ma
non ci crederà mai
buongiorno figlio di [ __ ] devi morire
dieci volte così fino a domani ragazzi
ce la sto facendo non ci posso credere
ce la sto facendo
sì sì dio mio è qua devo solo arrivare a
quella [ __ ] porta in fondo la donna
primo che si gira male lo prenda sempre
cazzo siamo più alta zio ha ballato e
bevuto più di tutti adesso adesso che ci
siamo reagan dovere
cosa faccio c'è un android ragazzi un
androide bruttissimo ecco infatti e l'ho
anche liberato porca [ __ ] tra tutti i
tizi che devo liberare proprio lui no no
no mi stanno sul culo voi cosi legato io
io ti ho liberato quindi tu appartieni a
tu appartieni a me
ok mi fai girare i [ __ ] le mazzate
sul mezzo c'è un tizio ma ragazzi se no
non ho mai visto non ho mai visto forse
perché sono un robot vede alien cioè
agli anni fa il culo non perché vorrei
capirla sta cosa più quadrini devi devi
arrivarmi in faccia proprio non è
contento se no ci siamo questa [ __ ]
procedura d'evacuazione ok potrei cela
dovrei fare finché quel tizio non mia
non arriva rompermi i [ __ ] teoria ok
ci siamo madonna no no no no no no no
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
salve ascolti svolti hanno preso non ha
preso che botta di culo
che botta di culo ragazzi ragazzi
se per caso alieni sente adesso sono
nella merda ma quella più totale proprio
na sega vento rumori brutti però sono
amici sti figli tutta na cioè maschi
fare un attimo geomar se io in giro per
la navicella non va bene se gira rienzi
però ma che problemi mentali cia il
freddo se ne sia credo è non so dove
devo muovere il culetto abbastanza
velocemente gioco è la cosa più
impossibile che io abbia mai non di
miche no no no no no no che culo
ho trovato madonna che nascondiglio
all'ultimo all'ultimo secondo proprio è
quella la porta e ce la posso fare
non ci voglio credere sì sì sì sì l'ho
fatta giovanni fontana la punta no no
il cazzo è che due commesso due ore vi
prego ti prego successo è morta a caso
no schiaffo sonoro anche non sono morto
la chiara ragazzi direi che posso
concludere qui l'episodio perché
annuncia posso più fare sotto tragico i
ragazzi servito mi è piaciuto ma sento
lasciato un commento mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook e come noi video
tratte descrizione come se vorresti
discreto incivili
minchia che ditata nell'occhio e noi ci
rimettiamo in un prossimo video e da
ragazzi